The Joe Rogan Experience Marlon Brando
oh yeah they had a little little gay
parties little girl eyes watch Chef
parties I'm sure he had a lot of that
God damn it I forget what it was now
oh that's brand new fat 300 pounds
Marlon Brando fat 300 pounds moved to an
island
and then that was it I'm not gonna get
it
it'll come back once you stop thinking
about it it will
what is what is that when that happens
the weird thing okay so the brain just
stops thinking about the thing you were
just thinking about no I saw a study
man and I can't name it study I should
probably shouldn't quote it but they oh
now I remember what it was there it is
thank you this is what it was Marlon
Brando when he won the Academy Award did
not accept the Academy Award instead had
a Native American woman go up there and
accept the award and it turns out she
wasn't really Native American
it was she was in her [__] sister
ratted her out I believe
haters
but she's beautiful I mean like and
she's probably crazy
um but if you uh find the video it's
kind of funny because like accepting the
ward Four Mile and Brando and she goes
up and talks about I think she talked
about Native American genocide which was
just figurative American she just made
it up she just she changed her name like
the whole deal what was her name
did he know sasheen Little Feather
little feathers you just call yourself a
little fat
he didn't know he's Marlon Brando he's
on an island [__] everybody that
moves
so this lady was not Native American at
all so the look at the Academy Award
what's that I heard the Wikipedia says
she's from Oxnard
wow
and her sister was like you [__] you're
not [__] Native American imagine like
your sister is crazy and you hate your
sister and you're always fighting and
then one day you see that [__] at the
Oscars telling everybody she's an Indian
but yeah
yeah but how she feel
watch her talk
she kind of does
I mean she could be
here again
hello my name is sasheen Little Feather
no it's not and I'm president of the
national Native American affirmative
image committee I'm representing Marlon
Brando this evening and he has asked me
to tell you in a very long speech which
I cannot share with you presently
because of time but I will be glad to
share with the Press afterwards that he
very regretfully cannot accept this very
generous award
and the reasons for this being are the
treatment of American Indians today by
the film industry
excuse me
[Applause]
and on television in movie reruns
and also with recent happenings at
Wounded Knee
I beg at this time that I have not
intruded
Wounded Knee was quite a long what is
that before that why'd you say recent
happenings at Wounded today it was a
protest there assigned oh right right
right
her uh ancestor dispute here like after
after her death though which is kind of
oh that's when she got busted her
biological sisters Rosalind Cruz and
Trudy Orlandi who say the family does
not have Native American ancestry Keeler
writes that the sisters state that their
father who was born in Oxnard California
was a Mexican descent and had no tribal
ties nor was he related to the Yaki
tribes of northern Mexico furthermore
Crews believed Little Feather fabricated
a native identity because she thought it
was more prestigious to be Native
American than to be Hispanic Keeler
searched records for little feather's
family going back to 1850 and did not
find evidence of native ancestry so she
got away with it damn Little Feather
walked so Rachel Dulles all could run
yeah well you know
you know back then there was no social
media like your friends from college
couldn't tweet and go what right right
where the [__] you know that's one of
the things that happened with Elizabeth
Holmes that lady who ran that thrano
scam oh man who created a fake voice a
king scammer her friends from college
like why is that [__] talking like that
they would like to call each other up
hey have you heard her on the news why
is she [__] talking like a party like
totally and then she she gets on the
stage she's like we're really excited to
bring you the most amazing
blood data research from a drop of blood